Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a message, a Dawah center.
Establishing a message to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So, that makes the reward
even greater. So, give generously and
Allah Azza wa Jal will give you even
more.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? I'm
joined with a man with very good pajamas
today.
>> [laughter]
>> Wearing the blue pajamas. So, I had to
do the color combination.
>> yeah. I just realized now.
>> You know what I mean?
>> What we were doing.
>> I'm one step ahead of the game.
>> god.
How are you?
>> You You know who wasn't one step ahead
of the game?
>> Who?
So, is it Hamza?
>> [laughter]
>> He's in the Epstein files.
>> Is he? Well, indirectly because
obviously Krauss is mentioning Krauss is
mentioning it to Epstein. He's trying to
show off to Epstein that someone in the
course of that debate or after that
debate had some kind of doubt. One
person, he could only find one person,
which by the way is an admission of
guilt of of weakness actually.
>> Yeah.
>> Because he's saying I could only find
one person after the debate which was
seen seminal debate actually, one of the
most watched Muslim atheist debates of
all time. Um I think now maybe 10
million views.
>> Something like that.
>> Yeah, so for those people that don't
know, Lawrence Krauss is a very or was a
very prominent figure of new atheism. It
was a movement to about Would you say 5
years ago?
Yeah, about 5 10 years ago and there
were some significant figures. He wasn't
off the four, but he was somebody that
had you know, that was very close to the
Richard Dawkins. He's an American and he
wrote a whole book on what is nothing.
>> wrote a book called The Universe from
Nothing. Yeah. And he concluded He he he
he he he he he
>> Nothing is something. Exactly. Yeah, so
the the the
he wrote a book called The Universe from
Nothing, yeah. But then in the course of
debate, he defines nothing as like a
vacuum and space vacuum and stuff like
that. Uh it was revealed that he means
something by when he says nothing. So it
was just kind of then he said it was
just like marketing and it's jargon and
it's nonsense. He was exposed in that
debate. Um but what I found really
interesting, bro, one of the most
interesting things for me, obviously
we've been a we've been going against uh
new atheists for a very long time.
We've been uh going against them. Is the
email interaction he had with Epstein.
Like a child. He's kind of like showing
him like this um priest Satan priest,
you know, that I've I'm bringing people
away from the the path of Islam. In
particular Islam, yeah. One person.
Yeah, so [snorts] one person which which
you I don't we don't even know if he
became an apostate or not, but yeah, and
he he's saying that he brought somebody
away from the path of Islam.
And then Epstein responds. Do you have
the full script of it? Yeah, it's quite
long though. Let's read it cuz it's I
think it's worth it.
Krauss is showing Epstein
Yeah, this new atheist Krauss who was
demolished in the debate uh 10 what had
10 years ago now I don't know how long
it was ago with Hamza Tzortzis.
Yeah, one of the most watched debates.
He's trying to prove to Epstein that
he's done a good job. And this is how
Epstein's responding, yeah. He says, "I
won't dignify this this trite anecdote."
He's actually angry. He sounds angry. If
you had 1 million of these, it would not
be worth 1 day of your time.
And by the way, he's not putting like
capital letters in the the beginning of
sentences and stuff. He's not he's
he's not wasting his time with this guy.
If you want to be a rabbi,
>> [laughter]
>> do it. This is not science. This is
religion. And a total effing waste and
he spelled waste wrong of your unique
talents.
>> [laughter]
>> The idea that you found this meaningful
makes me sad.
>> [laughter]
>> And imagine Krauss shuts his mouth after
that. You've got this guy putting him in
his place. Because you know why? Because
Epstein is a superstitious man. He
believes in God. He believes in Baal. He
believes in
Satan. He does the magic himself.
His account was called Baal apparently.
>> [laughter]
>> That's how it goes. So I just found this
very interesting. And you got him, Sam
Harris now having a very cordial
discussion with Sam Harris being another
one of the four horsemen of new atheism
having a very cordial discussion with
Epstein coming to the island. When are
we going to come to the island? We can
read that if you want as well. Let's see
what what he said.
And while you find that, all four
horsemen, they call them the four
horsemen of new atheism, all four of
them are found in the Epstein files
except one.
Christopher Hitchens because the guy is
dead. Yeah? So other than that, Daniel
Dennett is there, Richard Dawkins is
there, Sam Harris. Yeah, look at this
one here. Sam, we met with John Brockman
at the TED TED event. I thought you
might enjoy a dinner with Woody Allen,
Chomsky and me. It should be fun.
Obviously, it's quite disappointing that
Chomsky is on this list because he's
been a good advocate of
Palestine
and and and other causes actually and
like against Western hegemony and stuff
like that. However,
I had a a discussion with Chomsky. I I
tried to in a soft manner bring up
religion. I found an aversion, you know?
So this doesn't actually surprise me.
And that's the thing I listened to the
Muslims as well. It doesn't matter where
somebody is
on the political spectrum. They could be
a a great Palestine supporter. It
doesn't mean they're necessarily one of
the good guys, you know? And you'll see
that on the the of judgment. We'll see
on the day of judgement who the good and
the bad guys are.
You know,
um even the Quran it says that the
people will say, "Where are
the men that we
thought were the people men that we
thought were the bad guys?" Yeah. They
they they thought that these men were
the bad guys and they they and the day
of judgement they won't be able to see
them. But what we can see, subhanallah,
is all the bad guys, all the ones who
used moral arguments against Islam,
yeah?
What That was their main argument, by
the way. But even before you get into
that, some people sometimes come and
say, "Oh, you know what? How is it fair
that God will place people in hellfire
just for not believing in him, but
there's so many good people." And I'm
sure Noam Chomsky's name would be on
that list.
>> Mhm. But then our counter response is,
"Okay, that's what you know on the
outside.
>> Exactly. You don't know what lies in
their hearts." He was great friends with
Sam Harris. As you can see, it's whole
like a it's a whole clique here.
Sam Harris like
Sam Harris is going to come down,
Brockman, you know, Epstein. I'm sorry
to say, but what do you think they're
discussing? Everyone knows what
Epstein's about. What do you think
they're discussing? What do you think
they're uh
talking about? So that's one thing. The
other thing is these guys will make him
moral arguments against Islam. Yeah. And
most of their arguments are the things
that they themselves are indulging in.
Yeah. They're they're engaging with the
most prolific sex trafficker
of all time, maybe. He's the most
prolific and notorious Yeah. sex
trafficker of maybe all time. And
they're engaging with him and they have
cordial relationships with him and they
have an excellent relationship with him,
although he was a through and through
hedonist, an abuser of children, a
person who, according to some documents,
he threw some of the bodies to the
sharks. Did you see that one?
I didn't see that.
>> that he was dealing with and stuff like
that. I don't know if it was the
children or whatever he was doing, but
they had sharks and stuff. You had this
woman from Mexico running out and
screaming and saying that she saw some
some things when she was on the island.
She escaped the island. There's a lot of
things that have been redacted and the
the US, the DOJ,
they've made it very clear that we have
not included killings and mutilation of
bodies.
But that's exactly what we what we need
to know about.
>> And and there's actually so much that
they have kept in, like for example, the
choking and the this and that. And so
this guy was involved in all of that.
There's evidence to suggest, when you
corroborate dates with the emails, that
a lot of those redacted names include
Netanyahu.
Oh, really? Yeah, Netanyahu himself. But
when when you search, I think his name
only comes up once. Uh-huh. But when
people are cross-referencing dates, when
it comes to certain things, he's in some
very concerning emails.
Well, I I think one thing that can be
said now is Subhanallah, Allah removes
the
the reputation of people that attack
Islam in a way that's even worse than
them just dying and
and and going under the ground. Yeah.
Which is that it humiliates them by
associating them with the most
the worst crimes that they would not
want to be associated with. He
humiliates them. This is a stain. It
doesn't matter how many degrees you've
completed, it doesn't matter how many
debates you've done, it doesn't matter
how many books you've written, it
doesn't matter how many moral points you
make about other religions. You are in
the Epstein files, Sam Harris. You are
in the Epstein files and you have a
cordial relationship with Epstein and
God only knows what you and him were
talking about on that dinner table. Mhm.
That's [clears throat] God only knows
what you were talking about with him.
And the thing is, he's not the only one.
We mentioned the four horsemen, yeah?
One of them that's passed away. And we
got Richard Dawkins as well, right?
>> course. Dawkins is there as well.
Dawkins who said that belief in God is a
virus. Yeah, it's a mental virus.
>> Yes. Yeah, and he's making such absurd
statements about God and religion,
calling it evil. But
all the while he was rubbing shoulders
with evil incarnate.
>> Maybe he's rubbing other things as well.
Absolutely. Yeah, [laughter] I don't
know if that that would be effectual
with his
impotence, both intellectual and
[laughter]
It seems to be a theme in your videos
though, isn't it?
So, Hawking Hawking Stephen Hawking
>> how's he going to be doing it?
>> [laughter]
>> How's How's he going to enjoy himself?
>> I really like this.
Is he doing this? Is he Is he shaking
[laughter] that thing? How's he
>> There's there's that meme of that guy
from Breaking Bad, isn't it? That
they're they're trying to find out who
did something to that guy in the
wheelchair and the the meme is saying
that's when Stephen Hawking's talking
about his sexual preferences when
[laughter] he's on the when he's on the
island. He's not the only one. There's
also you got Stephen Pinker there as
well. There's a lot of these atheists,
the very atheists that say, "We do not
need God. God is the epitome of evil."
And these are the same individuals that
have no objective morality. When they
are quizzed about this, they admit that
there is no objective morality. We don't
need it. And you know what? It is
subjective and this is the problem when
things are subjective.
>> that's what Richard Dawkins said in in
uh maybe a garden from
or maybe it could have been the blind
Actually, it's the blind watchmaker, one
of his books that he wrote. He said that
and he put it in a footnote try to get
away from it, but this is what really
what he believes. He says that there is
no good, there is no evil. It's only
pitiless indifference. It's just
whatever. There is no objective good and
evil and they realize that because the
the fact uh the fact is even John
Mackie, who wrote a book called Ethics,
he was one of the major atheists as well
before the time of these guys and a
proper academic. But in his book at the
end of it, he said that if someone does
not have a list from God,
then you can't have objective morality.
He's being honest about it. And the
Prophet Muhammad told us in
first now my if you don't have any
shame, if you don't have any shyness,
then do what you want.
And Dostoevsky said
that if you if God doesn't exist,
uh
everything is permissible.
And this is what Now it's you're seeing
the fruits of that on a sociological
level. People can't inhibit themselves
without a greater transcendental purpose
and reason for doing so. It's not enough
to say, "Well, I don't for consequential
reasons or whatever morality that Sam
Harris was trying to uh advocate in his
book The Moral Landscape."
It doesn't work in practice. You are
rubbing shoulders and maybe other things
as well with one of the most criminal
prolific criminals in human history and
that your consequentialist theories
didn't stop you from going on that
island or and
and all the those dinner tables with
with those guys. Yeah. All those years
speaking against God and religion and
talking about these obscure values, they
may sound all well and good on stage and
afterwards people will have a shandy or
whatever, but in the real world these
things don't work. If they did, these
people would be the models of society
frankly. If religion was bad, why is it
we don't see practicing Muslims in the
finals.
>> Yeah, in the finals. Why why is that not
the case? And also when you look at
Dawkins, uh these people have to admit
that if the world was created any other
way then the values [snorts] that we
hold true that they are evil, then it
it's conceivable that different things
would be considered evil. And if they're
so arbitrary, if they're so relative,
then how can these people actually say
that Epstein was a bad individual or you
know, some of the things that you and I
would agree are terrible? These people
can't because they believe it is
completely and utterly random. A you
know, different combination of particles
and atoms, we would have got something
else. And they actually believe maybe
even according to their view some of
them are determinists. They believe that
you know what? Yeah, they are determined
by the forces of nature to do what
they're doing. So, you
To speak to F site and go and then take
it with him and speak to him.
Apparently, it's okay according to his
world view. What would be wrong with it?
That's the truth of what they believe.
And it shows you that not having a
religion leads to all of that. But
subhanallah, Allah tells us this when he
says,
that Allah likes to distinguish that he
wants to distinguish and differentiate
the good and bad.
That he puts all of the
the
the the the evilness together and he
puts it together and he aggregates it
together and then he sends it to the
hellfire. And subhanallah, Allah
sometimes before the the ultimate
destruction of these individuals in the
day of judgement and the hellfire where
they'll be snap crackling crackling and
popping in the hellfire. Absolutely.
>> And they'll be burning therein for their
crimes against humanity and their a
crimes against God. He likes to show
right before they die like Richard
Dawkins is on the cusp of death in his
80s. He wants to humiliate him, yes, and
he wants to humiliate all of these
atheists in a manner that would befit
befit their
their lowly status. Punished in this
world and in the hereafter.
>> And that's all we have to say about
that.
Your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a masjid, a
dawa center.
This center, this masjid, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam. So,
give generously and Allah Azzawajal will
give you even more.
>> [music]